in today's challenge episode we're going
to attempt the unreturnable serve see if
hearing affects ping pong and more let's
get into it three table tic-tac-toe
let's go
yes
no i need one more
oh
i need the back one
you got the middle
i have two chances now you have three
chances
[Applause]
[Music]
you took it from me
come on thank you good care good job
that was fun the idea is to serve a
serve so short
that it bounces onto the metal part
and rolls
on the table easy peasy ten tries ten
thousand tries
[Music]
i think it's still bouncing there now
you see what we're trying
five minutes gone
come and join the fun of trying the
impossible
all this effort
just to get a net serve one hour and
five minutes
come on michael you can do it i think i
need a good luck gong
lunatic
we were almost losing it
after 90 minutes
you didn't even need a chocolate break
no we have this challenge where we built
the biggest chocolate racket if we hit 5
million subscribers make sure you hit
subscribe
yes
let's fly it's not there anymore let's
try to swat some ping pong balls
[Music]
[Applause]
okay should we move on to the electric
sweater
anybody has water i think i've read in
the school that that's not the best
combination but we'll see
[Music]
bouncy ball plus world's spinniest table
i think i need my bandana for this i've
just washed my hair so it's all fluffy
and in my eyes don't like me cause you
never wash your hair
okay
the bounce is hard
that was dangerous
oh nobody in this hall is safe we
haven't tried the spin yet
[Music]
how did it bounce that way
for a bit more spin
oh that's good
[Music]
we're gonna need some safety equipment
for the next challenge safety first
but what does this sound like sensei
racket on steroids i boosted it let's go
okay
i'm a bit scared i'm terrified
oh yeah but they are playing
surprisingly well i'll try to clean the
legs
what
do you not try this at all or anywhere
else either for example this one yeah
okay
i think we're done let's go find out how
they are feeling after this it was
actually really fun and it was a really
good exercise you can skip all the
jogging and you can just go play table
tennis in a truck let's move on to the
next challenge so the idea is to get one
shot on can go one meter back another
shot one meter back i think six should
be possible eight is realistic
let's show let's see what we are made of
let's prove him wrong
one meter
two
three are you on the shore eight meters
yeah i feel like i've got the distance
[Music]
crazy enough
one two three four five six
seven
[Music]
days
yo
we got it
almost seven and a half okay so we're
gonna try to play table tennis without
hearing at all so we're gonna put ear
plugs and ear muffs on and see how that
affects gameplay
like i can't hear much but i can still
hear the high pitch noises so the next
phase is to have some wireless
headphones
i'll even put the music as loud as
possible i'm speaking very loudly
so that i can hear myself
[Music]
whoa this looks like a new world to me
[Music]
i don't think it affects so much the
gameplay but it's just cool experience
vision with only one eye so half wishing
[Music]
kind of like need to face more here
final stage is to try them both
[Music]
it's just the itch it's itch can i try
so don't say anything if you agree that
i'm a much better player than you
oh well and he even know that
it's so hard
[Music]
so we need to recreate edward
scissorhands and it's gonna be emil
paddle hands
why are we doing this that's a very good
question oh my god i'm gonna have
nightmares from that
okay sir
okay wait a second
ah
much better than the previous one please
for this ammo paddle hand i'm ready
[Music]
whoa did you get them all you have
enough rackets
[Applause]
this this is tough like surprisingly
tough i think we can draw the conclusion
that it's not an advantage to have six
racquets i think it's time to try what i
was born to do emil paddle hands with
six battles on his fingers he had one
goal
six shots on at the same time proving
the world they're wrong
that was his only mission
[Music]
everybody said he wouldn't become a
table tennis player get off the table
he had the motivation and it's all come
down to this day
emil paddle hands